the eggplant is one of the only
vegetables that can pull that off it's
on an island of its own you wish it's a
meal the eggplant is a meal I wouldn't
want it a super
perfume
you see this thing you're like this is
going to be a wonderful parmesan
experience you cut that crust the
breading slides off the wet ass eggplant
oh you're having bad eggplant parm no a
stuffed mushroom can have all of the
food groups and the entire food pyramid
well so I don't think that's to be taken
lightly I think I think a stuffed
mushroom is absolutely good enough to be
an entree number one serum as entrees
then why the way that is sized stuffed
mushroom dish the crab meat and the
stuffy Elevate the mushroom but I don't
think it's I don't think it and you know
what Mike I agree with you a little
farther I was speaking I will take it a
step further